good afternoon of the rules
committee for Monday February
twenty fifth is hereby called
order of fifty advice an audio
and video recording of today's
proceedings being made as also
being televised amount sector
please call the roll Cooley
here Cunningham Carillo here
flora here Grayson Kamlager-Dove
here Maienschein Mathis here
quirk Silva here from us here
previous Wicks here we have
we have a quorum and we have
a consent agenda is our motion
on the consent agenda motion of
second by Mister Mathis
thank you very much --
that is yeah matter sector
please call the roll Cooley high
school late night Cunningham
Carillo Carillo aye flora
flora I agree Senate race and I
Kamlager-Dove Kamlager-Dove I've
Maienschein Mathis at the
site Burke so that's right for
example I Ramos from us I
Reavis Wicks works I suppose
that motion passed and --
the assembly rules for the use
that turned and will
sit here in case our college